et affirmer le sida comme un défi et le
relever avec moi très bien la réalité
c'est bouleversant et puis je pense que
c'est important que les gens qu'on sache
ce qui le combat qui a dû à l'époque
premières impressions de quelques-uns
des premiers spectateurs du film 120
battements par minute et jouer un peu à
domicile en région centre val de loire
d'abord parce que le film a reçu le
soutien de la région et l'appui
logistique de son agence culturelle
cycliques aussi parce que plusieurs
séquences ont été tournées dans l'ancien
hôpital d'orléans
il ya des scènes très poignante très
forte qui se passe dans l'hôpital dans
les décors qu'ils ont recréé dans cet
ancien hôpital
évidemment ça fait un petit un petit
truc bizarre retraçons l'action des
militants d'act up dans les années 90 au
moment où le sida entamé ses ravages 120
battements par minute a souvent été
qualifiés de films chocs coup de poing
c'est surtout pour les spécialistes
un film qui va faire date ah c'est un
film qui va rester c'est un film
important c'est ses films importants de
par ce qu'ils racontent parce qu'ils
véhiculent de par l'émotion qu'il
provoque idée important parce que il
rappelle le le travail extraordinaire
qui a fourni au top
les personnes qui étaient derrière
puisque il ya une association mais en
même temps il ya des gens qui font vivre
120 battements par minute est à la fiche
de quelques salles en région centre val
de loire et pour une durée encore
indéterminée
et aux problèmes sociaux